what blew your mind the most about the
mechanics of grogu's performance so
there's two one there's like remote and
you can carry him around and it is the
most immaculately made realistic looking
creature his his head will move around
ears you know what I mean like turn
towards you as you're holding them and
stuff like that and kind of be alive and
then there's one for the close-ups and
stuff then that's where you get the
really detailed eyebrow movements and
eyeballs kind of moving around and he's
a very cooperative and fulfilling scene
partner acting partner like having to
say goodbye to him in season two and
getting praise for oh my gosh like you
know you you you have such subtle
emotion and you're dealing with a puppet
and I'm like this puppet is making me
cry you know it's like no you know
you know I fully and I'm like damn I was
like whoa you know you're really chewing
up the scene on this one aren't you and
he's like
it's like the one time I have my helmet
off like let me let me have the scene
bro